Mysteriöse dinge spielen sich gerade in der antarktis ab ein instrument das eigentlich ultra auch energetische neutrinos aufspüren soll
hat etwas sehr seltsames entdeckt teilchen ströme die auch auf ultra energetische teilchen hinweisen aber
aus der erde kommen neutrinos reagieren zwar nicht mit materie wenn sie durch die erde fliegen diese teilchen waren aber so hoch
energetisch dass sie als neutrinos land doch von der erde materie hätten
aufgehalten werden müssen was sind das also für teilchen was ist da passiert
am südpol fixum science fiction bei uns gibt es täglich neue science videos abonniert den kanal gerne herzlich willkommen
Die antarktis ist ein unglaubliches messinstrument ein riesiger detektor mit einem volumen von 1,5 millionen kubikkilometer
und im eis der antarktis
diesem sektor passieren seltsame dinge zum beispiel entsteht dort die sharing yankov strahlung das ist einleuchtend
dass durch die kollision von neutrinos mit dem wassermolekül
des eises entsteht das icecube observateur über das wir ja schon berichtet haben
untersucht dieses leuchten und kann dadurch die geister teilchen die neutrinos erforschen
5160 sensoren wurden dafür tief in den antarktischen
untergrund versenkt und zwar bis zu 2,5 kilometer tief zusammen bilden sie ein riesiges dreidimensionales
detektor fällt so wurde dort erst im september
2017 der ursprung der neutrinos gefunden damals entdeckte der nasa
gammastrahlen satellit fermi eine riesige gammastrahlen quelle in der galaxie
txs 05 06 06 damals wurde der satellit aufgrund der messungen des ice cubes auf diese galaxie
ausgerichtet in zentrum ist ein glas ein aktives super massereiches schwarzes loch das eine extrem heiße
akkretionsscheibe um sich kreisen lässt und nach oben und unten jets ausspuckt einer trifft uns und wir können die strahlung messen zum einen die
gammastrahlung und zum anderen einige wenige neutrinos und ein solches wurde vorher im ice cube gefunden und es gibt ein zweites
experiment dort im eis wahrscheinlich der einzige flugkörper der nasa ihr auf der erde
ein instrument das an einem heliumballon in 35 kilometern höhe über dem südpol schwedes zeichnet radiowellen
auf die auch durch neutrinos ausgelöst werden und zwar sind es ganz besondere neutrinos nämlich ultra hoch
energetische die mit dem eis reagieren und einen der tcherniakov
strahlung ähnlichen effekt auslösen da sie hoch energetisch sind reagieren sie mit materie also mit dem eis
und lösen ware teilchen schauer aus kaskaden aus materie und antimaterie
elektronen und positronen
doch da sie als hoch energetische - mit materie reagieren können sie nicht durch die erde geflogen sein wie
diejenigen die im ice cube delektiert werden sie hätten dort bereits mit der materie der erde hinter agiert werden also aufgehalten worden
doch genau solche teilchen sind jetzt drei mal von anita gemessen worden sie waren hoch energetisch und
sind aus der erde gekommen also lösten ein partikel schauer aus und es können laut einem
forschungsteam der penn state university eben keine neutrinos gewesen sein sie können ja nicht aus der erde kommen wenn sie hoch
energetisch sind was ist das also das forschungsteam um den physiker der ipi fox geht davon aus dass es sich um
es aus handeln muss ein elementarteilchen typ der bisher nur hypothetisch also
vorhergesagt existierte niemand hatte ihn bisher gefunden und das wäre eine absolute sensation
damit wäre eine revolutionäre erweiterung des standardmodells der teilchenphysik
eingeleitet die supersymmetrie sie sagt voraus dass sich personen und fermionen ineinander umwandeln können und dass es toll wäre
genauso ein teilchen der super partner des deb-teams
einem schwester teilchen des elektrons damit würde wirklich eine neue ära der physik beginn fox meint sogar dass es möglich wäre dass es am
large hadron collider am cern in genf dem lhc zu untersuchen und sein team meint auch in den daten des ice cubes
ungewöhnliche schauer gefunden zu haben alles noch ein wenig unsicher
tatsächlich wird das ergebnis des forschungsteams weltweit intensiv diskutiert aber noch ist der aufsatz
nicht peer reviewed worden und einige kollegen und kolleginnen meinen auch dass es andere erklärungen geben könne
wahrscheinlicher seien zb
unverstandene reaktion des antarktischen eises mit den neutrinos
oder oder oder ich bin jedenfalls extrem gespannt die ersten ungewöhnlichen teilchen schauer gab es 2006 und
2016 aber jetzt ist gerade wieder einer festgestellt worden und der wird gerade
untersucht wow so dass jetzt ein dickes brett ein echt schwieriges thema wenn er findet dass es spannend war dann
abonniert doch nix zum unerwähnt sogar mitglied mit einem kleinen beitrag tut der gutes wir schalten nämlich dann immer mehr
werbung vor den videos ab und ihr bekommt dafür extra videos live streams und noch ein paar andere
privilegien einfach unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den link in der video beschreibung und hier geht es weiter mit
rätsel um geister teilchen erde als gigantischer neutrino killer
dafür eben hier klicken früher bekommt in die videos übrigens über whatsapp von mir geschickt dafür hier klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt